de vrais cours mende ses abeilles une
goutte de miel sur le doigt permet de
les attirer à coup sûr mais au delà de
l'aspect amusant c'est une manière de
les apprivoiser et surtout de les
comprendre
thierry et christine sont apiculteur
depuis deux ans ils transmettent leur
passion
le fait aussi de les voir disparaître
dans nos jardins petit à petit le fait
d'atteindre qu'elle disparaisse dans le
monde que la pollinisation est mise en
danger que par exemple dans certaines
régions de chine les hommes sont obligés
de faire de la pollinisation à la main
parce qu'il ya plus d'insectes
pollinisateurs
naturellement quand mes enfants sont
devenir grand et que j'ai eu plus de
temps j'ai un style ma première ruche
dans mon jardin et j'ai contacté france
miniature pour sensibiliser les gens
découverte de l'intérieur d'une ruche et
animations autour du miel france
miniature confirme son engagement pour
la préservation des abeilles
le parc utilisent plus de pesticides les
fleurs sont laisser plus longtemps dans
les pelouses et deux ruches ont été
installées pour les enfants on propose
des ateliers où on leur fait construire
une petite abeille fabriqués une abeille
en papier on propose également des
ateliers de fabrication de bougies en
cire d'abeille et puis c'est vraiment
l'occasion pour nous de passer des
messages pour que les gens soient
sensibilisés au fait que l'abeille noire
notamment kate une abeille locale est en
voie de disparition donc on explique
avec quels gestes simples on peut faire
en sorte de la préserver ça leur permet
de s'apprivoiser un petit peu avec le
monde de la nature de poser toutes leurs
questions de façon ludique ces
butineuses se laisse approcher par les
visiteurs tous les dimanches du mois de
juin
thierry et christine donne même des
conseils pour les accueillir dans vos
jardins